it was a rare moment of bipartisanship
in a divided Congress welcome to the
most bipartisan Committee in Congress
we may not always agree on how to get
there but we care about our our national
security here at issue here of free
speech rights Federal control of social
media and National Security issues
in recent Days shows the chu and his
team have been lobbying in Washington
including meeting with each member of
this committee the charm offensive
carried on Tick Tock itself I'm super
excited to announce that more than 150
million Americans on Tick Tock there's
almost half of the US
but Congressional critics were not
deterred
Tick Tock is a grave threat of foreign
influence in American Life
it's been said it's like allowing the
Soviet Union the power to produce
Saturday morning cartoons during the
Cold War
but much more powerful and much more
dangerous and I'm going to put a shot
and shown to the committee disturbing
Tick-Tock content that was found on the
feed of a 16 year old who killed himself
by jumping in front of a train it's
alleged the content contributed to his
suicide we must save our children from
Big tech companies like yours number one
we will keep safety particularly for
teenagers as a top priority for us
Chu insisted Tick Tock didn't share
information with the Chinese government
saying the company would take steps to
ensure independent monitoring of data
use all protected U.S data will be under
the protection of U.S law and under the
control of the U.S led security team
a few liberal members of the House have
opposed the move to shutdown Tick-Tock
the primary fear that this would be
against the First Amendment the freedom
of speech clause in the Constitution
but it appeared the majority support
either shutting the app down or forcing
the sale to a U.S company
the FBI director has told Congress that
Tick Tock represents a national security
threat the federal government has
ordered that it be removed from all
federal devices
the previous administration attempted to
shut Tick-Tock down but the move was
stopped by the courts and whatever
emerges from these hearings this likely
at some stage to be a protracted legal
argument based on First Amendment
grounds
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington